[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERICA: Hi, I'm Erica.
KOMAL: And I'm Komal.
We're from Google Developers
and here to tell you
about Developer Student Clubs.
ERICA: Developer Student
Clubs train thousands
of student developers globally
and work with their communities
to solve real-life problems.
SPEAKER 3: I'm sure you're
curious how it works.
Google selects amazing
students from across the globe
once a year to be a
Developer Student Club lead
and start a club
on their campus.
SPEAKER 4: These
clubs host workshops
to help students learn
about Google technologies.
SPEAKER 5: And they work with
local businesses, startups,
NGOs, even their universities,
to build real solutions
for real problems.
SPEAKER 6: These leads
believe knowledge is power
and that technology can
do extraordinary things
for the world.
ERICA: They take on
the responsibility
to help students learn and
empower these students to solve
real problems around them.
SPEAKER 7: Through
this experience,
they not only bridge the gap
between theory and practice
for students, but leave
a legacy of impact.
ERICA: Join us in building a
global community for students.
[MUSIC PLAYING]